[Musique]
c'est important parce qu'il est important
que nous établissions que nous sommes un pays
qui a les bras ouverts et non
des frontières fermées pour les gens c'est important
parce que nous faisons savoir aux gens pourquoi l'Amérique
est ce qu'elle est il s'agit d'un idéal et
cet idéal est la liberté pour tout le monde  Je
[Musique]
pense que nous devons réaliser à quel point il est important
d'accueillir des gens dans notre monde mes
parents sont des immigrants ma mère a vu la
statue sur le bateau venir ici et
parfois nous tenons cela pour acquis
[Musique]
ce que nous voulions faire ici était de gentillesse  de
transmettre ce concept étonnant de Liberté
mais aussi nous voulions transmettre l'idée
qu'elle appartient à chacun de nous et que
nous devons comprendre que chacun
la voit un peu différemment
[Musique]
vous